the United States on the way back to its
old strength while there while China's
cloud is fading right at the moment the
roles of the big to economic powerhouses
of our times a completely different not
clearly allocated right now with what
consequences for the world economy that
it's the big question I want to discuss
with Oliver Rocco from Deutsche Bank
research obviously China and the US play
a very crucial role also for your
monthly calculation of the day bigs what
has happened there in July broadly the
divx has been stable across regions
however fundamentally speaking we are
seeing growth driven by the United
States and its acceleration whereas we
have growth weakening in China currently
and Germany for instance we have stable
growth as well the development worldwide
remains more or less flat you can say
the IMF is forecasting a growth of
three-point-three percent for this year
which would be actually a little
slightly under what happened last year
in 2014 a big breakthrough still far off
it seems that roughly tell us with our
own forecast and yes we also don't see a
breakthrough on the growth momentum it
really seems increasingly like we have
just to get adjusted to lower growth
momentum compared to what we had
pre-crisis for once credit boom is not
happening again right now and also a lot
of the growth the emerging markets head
pre-crisis has also run its course and
now we are not structurally lower growth
momentum well trade is another topic
were trade more or less plots along
Egypt just opened the wider the new Suez
Canal a few days ago hoping for more
ship cargo to go through in the coming
years is that ship cargo that additional
ship cargo really going to happen is
World Trade going to pick up in the
future and currently it really doesn't
look like that because we have World
Trade and nominal terms down substantial
year-on-year we have real trade growth
plotting along nearly stagnating even
though pre-crisis we had a World Trade
growing at double the speed of global
gdp for instance this is not happening
right now
and in the short run at least that was
what of course cloud in the outlook for
the new series cannot but structurally
long-term we believe world trade will
grow again and also faster than world
GDP so over the long term and this is a
long-term investment the Swiss can I
should be fine looking for the reasons
of the flat world economic development
where economies always talk about the
problems of the of the emerging markets
the current problems to what extends are
the BRIC countries and the other
emerging markets are they able to do
harm to the world economy well given
their size especially of China for
instance there is a noticeable impact of
those countries either in contraction or
slowing down on global trade on global
GDP as well especially Germany are given
its strong trade links to a lot of
emerging markets is effect on the
external side so yes this is dampening
global growth however luckily enough we
have domestic growth picking up in ian's
you we have domestic growth picking up
in the US and to some extent that's
keeping a global growth afloat basically
thank you so far until here the emerging
markets and their growth problems when
economist around the world talk about
that issue they're all very concerned
because nobody really knows in what
direction the emerging markets are going
to head in the future it's worthwhile
talking about that issue a little more
in detail we want to do that in our
focus interview of this month you can
see that as always online on DWS
homepage of our weekly business show
made in Germany